to say you know name your two or three
most favorite things
um after having spent so much time and
really kind of obsessing over uh
every word that he's ever said yeah i
think
um leverage and accountability are my
two on the wealth side
i think um to kind of briefly summarize
them like accountability is just a
more precise uh and fair kind of
phrasing of the old
folk wisdom like it takes money to make
or it takes wealth
uh it takes risk to make money like you
have to kind of
put yourself out there entrepreneurs
take on risk and what entrepreneurs
actually do is take accountability for
the risk that exists
you know they are willing to put
themselves out there you publish this
podcast and your newsletters and
everything under your own name like
that's accountability you have to be
willing to take on the downside if you
you know
take on the debt to start a new business
like you are personally taking
accountability for that
it doesn't mean you have to take risk it
doesn't mean you have to
actually like find the riskiest thing
that you can do you know the advice to
go take risk is actually like quite
dangerous
um the advice that you are accountable
for the risk that you take and you have
to very carefully
manage that risk like that idea is kind
of baked into accountability
um which is like a piece of nuance that
i thought um was really really helpful
to kind of
complement the folk wisdom of
entrepreneurship that's out there
um on the leverage side of things that
he really classified it as
capital labor and products with no
marginal cost of replication
um which is an asterisk but a little bit
of a mouthful
but that's software that's
podcasts media you know these things are
all relatively new and we're still
seeing how much they kind of change the
economics of some of these businesses
it doesn't cost anyone well maybe
youtube but you know
more for to serve it to 100 million
people than it does to 100 and so if you
create a great video
the meritocracy of the internet will
take over and you can have incredibly
outsized returns by using
this kind of productized leverage that's
out there so
um those are two on the well side on the
happiness side you know there's a lot of
kind of
little habits in there and and things
that he recommends and
um pieces of philosophy that he pulls in
but really that all starts with
realizing that
we're going to be here a very short time
in the scheme of things like
life is short the universe has been here
a long time it'll be here a long time
um and realizing that any moment that
you are not
choosing to be happy and choosing to
interpret the inputs of the world in a
positive way
you're not doing anyone any favors like
you're not making you're not making
yourself better
off you're not making the people around
you better off
and you are in control of that like you
can choose to be happy you can choose
positive interpretations
and when you do everyone around you and
you are better off for it
but no one can choose that for you you
have to choose it for yourself
um and so it is a you have to kind of
zoom all the way out to get back to this
tiny little
choice and this tiny little thing that
we all have but it's kind of a
core core piece and just reminding
yourself of that as often as you
possibly can can be a really
transformative thing for your for your
mindset and your mood and
and everything just kind of comes easier
when you remember that like it doesn't
have to be hard it doesn't have to be
miserable
you're not you're not more productive
because you're unhappy like
just choose a positive take on all of
this and like keep going
were there any surprises for you in
terms of uh putting this together um
either from the content or the process
yeah there were definitely some i mean
there were a lot of unknowns when i
started this project right
it came up so fast um kind of out of
nowhere
that at first my first idea was like hey
i put together like a little tiny ebook
you know a little thing those you know
20 pages
and then when i had all this material in
front of me i was like oh my god this is
this is huge i'm going to make a you
know 600 page version of it i'm going to
cover every category this is going to be
port charlie's almanac
maybe i should just build like a tool
that actually allows for live updating
and it's more of kind of like
a blog's thing that does it would be
have to be like a little transformed
because it's not about whatever's newest
it's about the best ideas and how you
combine them all
so there was a lot of kind of creative
crossroads along the way i wasn't sure
if i should be writing about naval's
ideas or
or just kind of getting out of the way
and letting them speak for themselves
um so it was tough to kind of navigate
some of those things and
find the right mix of constraints that
let me keep making progress
um i'm really really happy with where we
ended up there's every chance that that
this could have become something totally
different um if someone had given me
kind of a different
push along the way um trevor mckendree
actually writes like an awesome
newsletter
um i like brought him a mess of a
manuscript early on and i was like i
don't even know what this thing is
supposed to be
like is it going to be a blog is it
going to be a book
like how are we going to get there from
here and he's like don't ever think it's
a book just
get back to work um keep making it a
book
i was like okay that actually like
clears up a lot it just took the right
person to kind of like
slap me and and get me back on the road
and now all of a sudden i'm making
progress again
um the other the other kind of big thing
was just like how comprehensive should
it be
you know there was my first draft of
this manuscript was
600 pages it was well over 100 000 words
it was huge
um the final product for reference is
like less than 50 000
which is like much more of a normal book
but this was an encyclopedia for a
minute of like
everything interesting that i thought
naval had ever said
um which included you know sections on
blockchain and education
and investing and building startups
because all like
this is such a fun project for me
because i'm interested in all of the
stuff that nimal has said
um i think there's there's thought
experiments
and you know futurism and there's so
much stuff in there that i thought was
was important and interesting and
helpful um and it took a really kind of
broad wide range of peer reviewers kind
of
after that manuscript who i gave them a
600 page thing and they're like you'll
be [ __ ] kidding me
um and they all read like a different 60
percent
um but the all all of them loved wealth
and happiness
and so that was kind of a go figure
right like everybody wants to be
wealthy and happy and so those became
like the foundation of it and figuring
out what to put around that to give it
the right context
make it like a fast engaging kind of
awesome read i really want people to
power through the end of the book and be
like oh my god i wish this was longer
like that's the best compliment a book
can receive
um and all those sections are now kind
of published
on on the ballmenack.com so there's no
reason not to have them on the website
and put them out there for people who
are interested in it
but i really wanted them to power
through the book and then find their way
to kind of
different rabbit holes um based on what
they were interested in
but that that early kind of feedback on
the first first manuscript was
so key to get me through some of the
some of the things that
um was hard to see past what i was
interested in and and learn kind of what
other people
would want to see in it yeah it feels
like you've had this um
very intimate experience where you're
like spending all day with
uh the thoughts of somebody uh and
obviously it being the ball is um
is cool and valuable but how do you
think you've changed
just from spending that much time kind
of re-reading
so much of this kind of high quality
content uh and i've got to imagine
almost like searing it into your brain
to the point where like
you can literally call it back like a
database right of just like hey i know
exactly what
the thoughts are on this topic or that
topic like how have you changed
or maybe just your perspective changed
yeah it's it's actually
um i think you know when you've changed
when it's hard to pinpoint how you've
changed
you know um i definitely i mean i read
this book and
some of the source material like more
than 20 times in the course of building
this thing over
three years like there's hundreds and
hundreds of hours into this
um of just sitting with this material
and picking up a piece and trying to
kind of totally
figure out totally understand it and
figure out what else it relates to
um so i almost feel guilty at like how
many things i'm sure i adopted as my own
in this process that i'm like
this is now my idea but like it
definitely came from from this process
in this book
um but i think you know we are we are
all doing that we are all standing on
many layers of
shoulders of giants um so it has been
kind of part of that process but the the
this
kind of crucible of editing that i've
been going through
the reward for that is that i now have
like a little
like naval who sits on my shoulder like
he is on my mental board of directors i
have like a hogwarts portrait in my head
that to such an extent that like i can
almost ask it questions
and know what it it would say back um
and that that is a really high bar you
know you you don't have time to do that
with very many people
in in your life um to study an idea that
deeply or a person that deeply
and i'm very kind of grateful that
you know it was a very kind of a
luck-based thing that like this became
the book that i was working on like
i tweet dumb stuff all the time this one
just happened to turn into a book
and i'm very lucky that like this agreed
with
so much of what i wanted to know and
what i wanted to learn like um
um it would have been hard to sit with
three years of just anybody so like
picking who to study and who to kind of
whose ideas to let this deeply into your
head i think is is important and i'm
really glad that
um that we're over that threshold and
that like this is the bar that i reached
in working on this book
and you know for me personally it was it
was transformative to a point where like
i don't i would love everyone in the
world to read it and get something out
of it but i don't need that to feel good
about having spent this time
working on it like this was this is a
project for me from the beginning
um and i hope everyone gets something
out of it and i think many people
love it but i'm also would not be
disappointed in the time invested if all
it did was change me
and teach me things